les deux et je vous dis j'en parlais
tout à l'heure avec le président de ses
8 francs capitaux qui a longuement
discuté avec vous avez vu il me disait
j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour eux parce
que vous êtes des amours voilà je
voulais dire et c'est toutes mes équipes
me disent que ça a été un bonheur de
travailler que vous voilà donc merci la
saison 2 arrive et carrelage et une
petit truc c'est un petit truc pour toi
j'aimerais que tu viennes un petit peu
faire de du tpm paix avec nous à la
rentrée au moins une fois par semaine je
sais que dans la voix on en avait parlé
je trouve que vraiment et tu es génial
en plus que toujours souriante tu aimes
la vie est toi tu es avec moi au moins
j'ai besoin de personne avec moi dans
cette émission quelques nanas plus
jeunes voilà comment
tu peux alors j'aime pas quand tu
regardes les appels quand tu puisses
afin qu'ils peu de peine se sait c'est
quelqu'un voilà qui est encore là
regardez il regarde et qu'on regarde
comme elle bouge bien encore
c'est carla la reconnaît
ça va oui si tu aimes bien oui elle
nettement moins
pas du tout elle pas d'or regardez c'est
bien qu'un ses coutumes et une arrière
grand mère
c'est qu'on n'y voit rien arrière grand
mère les voilà voilà elle est là elle
est là ce soir les lyonnais de retour
c'est dingue
un car est ce que ça te dirait d'être
fait avec nous à l'eba pourquoi va
tenter une fois par semaine on peut
et c'est vrai qu'on a pas on n'a pas le
profil de carla non mais c'est vrai
voilà des centres de pernikoff qui est
pas d'accord
alors ces deux profils complètement
différent là on a la joie de vivre et
nicolas pernikoff c'est autre chose
c'est voilà la cd payne est pas il n'est
pas rentré il est dedans mais aulas d'or
ils sont ensemble d'ailleurs il sera de
retour nicolas
il sera de retour dès 2022 puisque enfin
le nom de nicolas sera de retour mais un
autre dur il est bien sûr il fait partie
et fera toujours partie de l'équipe je
parle pas de l'équipe ici de l'équipe le
journal rien ne le croyais vigen peut
pas
on n'avait pas toujours partie de
l'équipe bien entendu c'est mon ami il a
fait une très belle d un très beau début
de saison après forcément là il ya du il
ya du monde il ya du beau monde
franchement c'est vrai vous êtes tv tous
excellents je vais vous dire en venant
de fin d'année la fréquence vous êtes
une équipe extraordinaire on a fait on a
battu des records d'audience record donc
bravo à vous
parce que j'ai à vous dire ces records
d'audience ce n'est pas moi c'est vous
c'est vous les revenants et c'est
surtout les équipes aussi en
qualité au monde hymne d'amour
et toutes les équipes terre et fourvière
toutes les équipes de prod namory à
l'algérie d'ailleurs
alexis alex ne vois pas mon chéri
d'amour voilà tout le monde eric aussi
abidal lionel et voilà tous voila c'est
grâce à vous et à tous les cadreurs et
où vous le dire et je voudrais dire les
cadreurs jeu ils savent que je les aime
tous et c'est vrai que c'est un bonheur
de travailler que vous mes chéris parce
que je vous vois même je les vois c'est
le premier public et je les vois parfois
se marient derrière la caméra
c'est un bonheur de travailler avec vous
et bien sûr mon lionel stan à la
baguette un voilà le grand le grand
manitou celui à qui vous allez demander
de l'argent que vous savez je vous dis
non
et mokhtar mokhtar oui bah bien sûr
mokhtar sur mokhtar et à côté son ami je
crois que c'est son mec d'ailleurs
[Rires]
mais bon il rend constater la personne
est en érection
[Applaudissements]